okay good morning everyone and I'd like
to begin by thanking the organizers for
inviting me here and giving me the
opportunity to talk about some recent
work in my my group so people are in our
regulatory genomics community are more
familiar with expression to expression
models where basically you start with
transcriptomic data set and and and
learn which transcription factors might
regulate with genes by finding various
kinds of correlations among gene
expression patterns so for instance
mutual information based approaches from
Califano slab and thermodynamics based
approaches from the Rhinos lab and in
bullion circuit models from Herrick
davidson and colleagues in contrast what
I'm going to talk about is sequence to
expression models which are less
widespread than expression to expression
models and in the difference here is
that the TFS influence and the target
gene cannot be left as a gene-specific
free parameter which is often the case
in other in the e2e models but that it
must be predictable based on the sis
regulatory sequence in other words you
bring in the sequence and the presence
of binding sites and your understanding
of binding sites as a constraint that it
must be met by the by the model trying
to explain gene expression of the
function of TF expression so you go for
instance from order one parameter / /
pair of transcription factor and target
gene to one parameter or a couple of
parameters per transcription factor to
explain its to capture its biochemistry
globally and so it's a huge additional
constraint and various approaches have
been proposed over the years starting
with machine learning approaches and
linear models that were applied to yeast
data and Harmon was one of the pioneers
of the linear model approach and there
over 15 years ago also in the instant of
less work but some
some models were proposed and applied to
the software data and that's what we're
going to talk about in my talk today and
the one kind the kind of model I'm going
to focus on or talk about is semi
dynamics based approaches that we and
others have developed over the last ten
years or so and I won't say much about
contrasting these two men amex models
with more machine learning models except
to point out that often it's easier to
encode mechanistic hypotheses about in
these models for instance cooperative
binding of two transcription factors
that's distance dependent in a
particular way van general-purpose
machine learning models and we find it
to be more easy to use or suited for
modeling khana torial action of multiple
transcription factors which is a
hallmark of the developmental gene
regulatory networks that I'm I'm more
interested in these models have been
applied and studied in the context of
anterior posterior and dorsal ventral
patterning systems in the drosophila
embryo so for instance again work from
John Ryan seas lab and puppet senco and
levine david or nasty is been made
fundamental contributions and some work
from our lab as well basically these
models have two components there's a the
sequence parsing component where a
position weight matrix is used you wire
the log likelihood ratio score to
capture the strength of binding and so
that's shown here a transcription factor
bound to its binding side and there's
some binding energy that's or pseudo
energy that's that's coming out of the
PWM and then there are these
interactions imagined between just bound
transcription factor and the basal
transcriptional machinery or the
polymerase as well as protein-protein
interactions if any between two bound
transcription factors that are usually
left with three parameters and we know
one parameter / TF interacting with the
basal machinery or one parameter for any
pairwise cooperativity in a cooperative
interaction
and these parameters have been trained
and data the way this works is once you
set up this picture in terms of the
energies of interaction you you use
based simple ideas based on the build on
equilibrium thermodynamics to translate
energies of these configurations to
relative probabilities and then you
somehow go from those probabilities to a
prediction of gene expression one common
approach being the shakers model that
comes from the 1980s a typical model
fitting scenario for this would be where
in our context again the desala
segmentation you have the fly embryo the
interior is in the posterior and you
first measure the protein concentrations
of the relevant transcription factors in
this developmental stage you're
interested in so these are what y axis
is expression there two panels shown
here 11 for the activators one for the
repressors and you you know people have
measured these transcription factors as
a function of position along the axis
and then you also have the binding
specificities of those transcription
factors in the form of Matisse you take
an enhancer that you want to understand
or model you use the motifs to sort of
crudely parse these the enhancer in
terms of its candidate binding sites and
then using these transcription factor
concentrations and the candidate binding
sites you apply the thermodynamics model
to make a prediction of what expression
this this this this enhancer will drive
and there are two curves here one the
data and one the model prediction if you
try to fit so gem stat is this tool that
we developed in 2010 that captures some
of these ideas and adds some some novel
ideas and it's a it's it's an efficient
dynamic programming based implementation
and we showed in at that time how you
can fit the model well to several
enhancers from this interior the steerer
patterning the way to read each of these
panels is its interior to posterior at
y-axis is expression
the one of the lines the red line is the
data and where the enhancer drives
expression the blue line is there is the
prediction and each of these panels is a
different enhancer here is another paper
where we did similar things now we were
training one set of parameters for each
gene and the you know if you if you try
to explain less diversity of expression
with as many parameters you obviously do
better our challenge in this paper was
to actually predict the entire gene
expression rather than enhancer
expression so for instance take the
entire eve locus or entire harry locus
and predict their respective seven
stripe patterns which we were able to do
you know using a variant of the gem
stabbed tool today's presentation I'd
like to talk about a small story and a
longer discussion the first one the
first the short small story being how to
use or can we use DNA shape readout of
the sequence in place of the position
weight matrix which is what we've been
doing we and others have been doing so
far with these models and secondly going
towards ensemble models and experiment
design with enhancers so the first
shorter story is a including DNA shape
readout and the idea here i think this
this audience can already anticipate
what what what our interest would be
there's a lot of exciting work over this
past few years on trying to predict in
vitro binding specificities of
transcription factors more and more
accurately model them more and more
accurately and now we've been a sort of
outsiders to this excitement and been
observing these these advances and
wondering if these make a difference to
our models you know are they is the is
then in vitro ability to better read the
sequence and by intensive binding sites
going to help us in better predict gene
expression in the embryo or maybe
there's some biological limits or more
likely there's data limits that
cannot translate the improved the
improved reading of the sequence to
improve prediction so it's so it we were
open about what what we were going to
see in this and so what we did was we
were talking to Remo roses lab about you
know trying to learn about the these
shape features and and then we try to
incorporate these shape features into a
classifier for binding sites you know
Remo was presented yesterday about a
support vector regression based approach
here we had a sample of size rather than
PBM data with with expression so with
with the quantitative measurements so we
used a classifier instead and we trained
this classifier to tell the binding
sites of one transcription factor from
non binding sites this is a plot showing
how the shape score coming out of this
classifier correlates with the log
likelihood ratio scores so this
reasonable correlation which is not it's
not the same it's not the same
information exactly and then we went
back to our seminar ex-model and in
particular the place where a binding
site s is contribution to the expression
is is formulated and that part is where
there's a this is called a statistical
weight in the Boltzmann distribution and
the transcript this is the transcription
factor concentration and here is where
the llr comes in this is the llr of the
optimal optimal side and lr of the side
and the difference in l a-- Lars gives
you a sort of difference in binding
energies and that's how basically the
thermodynamics model works we replace
this part with a simple heuristic that
that takes in the shape score which is a
number between 0 and 1 and we it turns
out there has been previous work on this
kind of pseudo energy terms defined out
of arbitrary scores of goodness of a
side and then we put that's the only
change we had to do and then we were
ready to ask our question in this in the
same context that I've been working with
for the past several years the
there were 37 anterior-posterior
patterning enhancers 60 bins of our
positions of expression along the AP
axis so that's the variation in trans
context in which the in the man which
the model is being applied nine
different transcription factors and
their concentration profiles along the
axis and overall we found that in
several cases the use of the shape model
actually it leads to qualitatively
improve before a fist to the data so
here is an example where it's one of the
stripes of the gene run then where the
the PWM readout was the black is the
real expression pattern in the interior
of the embryo and the purple is the PWM
model which predicts this spurious
domain of expression and and then the
yellow or golden is the is the shape
based model which get cleans up this
spurious or topic expression domain and
so doing you know this is the plot that
shows it on more comprehensive level
that each point here is a enhancer this
is the goodness-of-fit called WP GP
which by the way we published two or
three years ago it was a difficult thing
to decide upon what's the goodness of
fit for this kind of data and and we
were able to come up with something
reasonable so that's the goodness of fit
on the the PWM based model the goodness
of fit based on the shape based model
and you know there were several cases
where there was a clear improvement yes
an activator that you predict shouldn't
have a site as the DNA shape that it
would be predicted to have a site of
right so that's I that's one of the
caveat is the second point you know when
there is disagreement it's it's not as
easy to go and pinpoint it on one site
being the cause of it and the reason is
that when you do these kinds of global
fits or over multiple enhancers one if
you have a different feature set to
which you ultimately find improving your
predictions you in the process change
your parameter settings the the new the
shape based model learns different sets
of different parameters we are in that
are utilizing those features exactly
differently from the from the sequence
based model and so it's not as easy
we're working on that still it's not as
easy to pinpoint what was the exact
cause because ideally what we'd like to
find is one binding site where the shape
readout is is different from the
sequence read out and is leading to the
better predict prediction of expression
and then mutate it in a way that the
shape readout changes but the shape
readout does not change the sequence
without changes something like that and
see if we see it the effect so that
would be what we'd like and will not do
not reach that point here also and the
other caveat is that the data used by us
on these were not really the kind of
quantitative data that raluca and you in
Martha's lab generates for for for
training these shape based models these
were sets of sites from bacterial one
hybrid and what we were able to exploit
is that these sites were slightly longer
so we could get some flanks and so on
but we did not have the quantitative
information and we'd really love to work
in a system where we ideally lie
the PBM data for these for these
transcription factors to to be able to
demonstrate the value much more
convincingly also there's that you can
you can have a very several questions
about controls and whether this point is
really established or not we've been
working on the manuscript and it's in
revision now and it should be out soon
so I apologize for not presenting
various controls that are necessary to
substantiate this claim of improved
performance ok so I can then now go on
to the second and major component of
this talk which is ensemble based models
of abortions of the gen staff model and
so the inspiration here comes from this
idea of strong inference as a paradigm
of science we're due to plat from over
50 years ago where I'll just read this
out strong inference consists of
applying following steps to a problem in
science dividing alternative hypotheses
dividing a crucial experiment with
alternative possible outcomes each of
which will as nearly as possible exclude
one or more of the hypotheses carrying
out the experiments s to get a clean
result recycling the procedure making
some parts ease and so on and I think
for many people this is so intuitive and
you know and and an obvious that that
this is what ought to be done but often
in in in in in the real world we are we
face a paradigm of of a single
hypothesis being formulated at at one
point and being tested and I understand
the constraints and motivations for for
that approach of one hypothesis is a
time but in in our context when we are
doing modeling and I'll explain what a
hypothesis is for us you know we can't
afford to go towards this strong
inference paradigm in the context of
understanding enhancer logic and so more
about the more away
a biologist is what is going is often
interested in knowing what they know
about then how about their enhancer and
and what should they test next which
sites should they knew to denies which
nucleotides or combinations of
nucleotides should they mutate to learn
most and it's not even clear what learn
most is you know they have an intuitive
sense of what they what perturbation
experiment would be appealing to their
colleagues and but it's not always
objectively clear what they would learn
from from doing that and whether that's
the right whether they would learn
something or whether they already know
the answer with high confidence and so
the the modest implementation of this
idea that I'm going to propose is to
think of parameterizations of the gem
stat model or similar models as
knowledge of enhancer logic and and then
frame these questions in in light of
these parametrizations so when you ask
what are the uncertainties in mind in my
knowledge of the enhancer ask a question
about the uncertainty of the of the of
the parameterization of the of the model
so that's the view point I'm adopting
here and i'll present a case study of
this kind of an enquiry over iterative
modeling an experiment that was done in
collaboration with star swordsman at
princeton and was led by my ex graduate
student his son who's sitting here can't
see him anymore but he's a postdoc in
katy pollard katie portlets lab at the
Gladstone and the case study is about
the dorsal ventral patterning gene
called ind expressed in the neuro
ectoderm and what that means is that so
think of this as the cross-section of
the embryo so the this way would be the
interior posterior axis and this is the
ventral dorsal axe
and there's this the there are various
nuclei across along the periphery that
have there are expressing different
genes and here's in purple here right
here is the IND gene and then you can
see that in this profile ventral on this
axis on this side dorsal on this side
expression and the IND gene is expressed
right here and we want to understand why
is it expressed their and wide and how
does the enhancer work and a good deal
is already known about likely regulators
of this gene in other words the grn a
rough gr and already existed so there's
dorsal the gradient it goes from ventral
two dorsal side and it's it's expected
to be regulator Zelda is a uniformly
present activator that's also expected
to be a regulator although not confirmed
and then snail vnd and Kokua snail is
expressed in in in this line here and
the mesa Durham vnd blue right next to
IND and Kappa Qi is a uniformly
expressed represses distri are likely to
be repressors and there's also a
signaling input coming in from from map
case signaling in the form of orc and
that also has been implicated through
genetic experiments so there are these
various players that are known that lead
to this precise expression of this ind
gene right there along the DV axis and
we want to understand we want to
quantify the logic of this enhancer
they're working of this enhancer the
enhancer is also known it's 1.4 k be
long and and we want to under this
enhancer understand this function so in
this case instead of what is commonly
done with these model fits is you you
know you do a search over the parameter
space and you find the best
best parameters best fitting parameter
vector and usually you rely on the fact
that you're fitting multiple enhancers
simultaneously to constrain your model
but in this case we were we wanted to a
model just this one enhancer and stas
wasn't willing to allow us to bring in
other enhancers but for which we do not
know the the players completely this is
what he you know he won he was confident
he understands this qualitatively he
wanted to make this quantitative so we
did not have the luxury of constraining
the model through through many other in
hamsters and so we we fit this and
you'll find but instead of finding the
single best fit we tried we went about
finding all parameter vectors that
produce a good fit and so what we did
was we it was about 13 dimensional space
or parameters we sort of deeply sampled
it's uniformly did some initial
filtering of parameters that fit the
data well and then did local
optimizations so that's a lot of samples
filter and find some of them that fit
the data and then improve the fit and so
we had a large an ensemble of many
different parameter vectors each of
which produces a curve like this red one
so there's this little shaded region
that shows that all of those models that
we found were very close to the purple
one which is the data okay so there's a
large not as a large ensemble of models
that fits the data well and at this
point and then we did various things to
visualize these models as well and
realize that there was quite a bit of
diversity in terms of what the models
were saying mechanistically in one model
1 activator may be dominant and the
other mild and another model the
opposite may be true in one case one
repressor is playing no role in another
case that repressor is playing a big
role so there's a there's a large
diversity of of biochemical roles or
activating in repressive roles of these
transcription factors in the models that
can explain this via the sequence
so then we went and found other
experiments that had been done with
these were the same enhancer where is
perturbation experiments that had
knocked down two of the repressors and
had mutagenized the binding sites of a
third repressor and we found that the
some subset of the initial wild-type
ensemble would fit these data and so we
filtered the initial ensemble and then
we had a final ensemble that goes
through the wild-type data as well as
the perturbation data and we then
predicted the effects of small
perturbations such as single binding
site mutations so here are three
predictions that we made with the final
ensemble with one was a particular
binding site for dorsal we predicted no
effect and it turns out there was an
experiment in the literature that had
found no expert effect for what is
believed to be the main activator or for
viral not mutating a binding site for
the main activator of this of this
enhancer and there was no effect and he
found no effect however there were other
binding sites okay there were other
binding sites for the same activator we
said well we predict that if you knock
down those other multiple binding sites
we will see an effect like this so this
is the wild type this is the prediction
and we experimentally tested this star
schwartzman and gerardo jimenez labs
were involved in this and he found that
the that the the the expression went
down it did rid was not abolished like
we had said and it was it went down
quantitatively at it to an extent
similar to what we had predicted and
thirdly we also predicted that when you
knock down a Zelda binding site or three
binding sites again you'll see a drop in
expression not an abolishment and that's
what we saw this is the images of the of
the embryos the wild type and and
knocked and the Zelda site mutagenized
and these are quantitative parsing of
those images to show that the expression
really goes down quantitatively to an
extent predicted by by the by the models
and
I think we find this very cool that we
were able to predict the effects of
these single or few site perturbations
and the end to a quantitative degree
that is it's not a matter of in the
expression going away or or grossly over
expressed but but but a more
quantitative level what we are doing now
by the way so this is all this is
published in a recent paper the where
sound was the lead author and this was
in cell systems and what we're doing now
is to go from here to a more
probabilistic version of the landscape
so for instance you know if you imagine
the parameter space and our ensemble
creation generating these for good
parameter vectors we'd like to go from
there to something like this so and have
a probabilistic landscape over the over
the ensemble of models so this is a 2d
version of that those are all good
models that were revealed by the by our
procedure we would be the way we we cast
a probabilistic landscape over these
models is so you realize it's an
ill-defined problem it's you know it's
you you want a probability landscape
that from which these points might have
come but they're not supposed to be
there not expected to be a samples of of
that landscape because there was an
optimization step involved in getting
these points so what we do here is sort
of drape multiple Gaussian distributions
over different clusters of this problem
of these of the ensemble the idea being
that each cluster is sort of a
mechanistic domain it's the region of
parameter parameterizations that are the
similar mechanisms or the same mechanism
and so if you find these clusters and
and then and put the Gaussian peak a
Gaussian around on each of them in fact
we put a mixture of gaussians for each
cluster and then there was a mixture
over those clusters that's the landscape
we use to then be able to do additional
things with the ensemble so for instance
we are this is a
this is a work looking at this at mute a
single nucleotide mutations in the IND
enhancer and using our probabilistic
landscape to put standard deviations
around our predictions and and then ask
well which is here's a snip that we
predict to have the largest effect but
it's actually not seen in the population
you know it would be cured be curious to
know if the model it was right about
this petite to the fact and it's really
avoided in the population here is a snip
that's a moderate effect that's
predicted to be compensated by another
snip so there's we think that this nip
should have this moderate effect but but
that it and seen the population and we
believe it's because it's caught there's
another snip that's compensating for it
so we'd like to know that's the case
here's another snip which is just the
largest effect predicted effect in the
population and so we are testing these
very snips you know from in in the in
collaboration with the jimenez lab in
barcelona another thing we're doing is
using the probabilistic ensemble to
evaluate an experiment and the idea is
that once you have this probabilistic
landscape you can I know this so let's
say this is the wild-type landscape this
do after a certain perturbation
experiment was done and this is after
another if perturbation experiment was
done well you can quantify the entropy
of the landscape as your measure of your
uncertainty of knowledge of the of the
enhancers logic and then you measure the
change in entropy and and and ask which
one which experiment was more
informative in this context I'm almost
done in this so in this context i'd like
to point out then when i talk about
these ensembles of models and and having
learned something because we ruled out a
large number of mechanisms people ask in
a biologist often ask me well that that
doesn't make much sense to me you know
what exactly did you learn and so you
have we have to convey to the biologists
what was learned from an experiment not
just as though you know as a reduction
of what mechanisms were ruled out but in
a language that they can they are more
Miller width and so here's one
visualization of that this is this panel
is about a particular experiment that
was done on the site on by mutating this
kappa Keeler binding site and what I'm
saying is that before we knew the X
result of this experiment the result of
this other experiment was very uncertain
we didn't know what's going to happen we
didn't know when if you mutate dorsal
side what should you see but after
knowledge of this experiment one result
of this experiment 2 becomes clear in
other words they are not they can we
understand now that dorsal this
particular dorsal side does play does
not play a role in this enhancer and
that turns out to also be the reality so
this first experiment was informative of
the effect of this other experiment and
that's something concrete for the
biologists tool to take back as
something learned from these experiments
so the future work we want to do here is
that it towards experiment design you
know you once you have a probabilistic
landscape over the current good models
you can calculate an unexpected change
in entropy these are ideas in the
literature is in the experiment design
literature which is quite rich in old
you can calculate an expected
information gained from a particular
experiment and then choose the
experiment that you believe you expect
to have the greatest information gained
and i'll skip the last part which is
about using regularization to in these
sorry for just moving over these we've
shown that regularization or in
particular one form of regularization
called noise regularization helps in
further trimming down the landscape even
without additional data so in summary
I'd like to think of gem stat as a null
model of that in for interpreting
sequence it's it no we all agree that to
first approximation activators activate
and you know if you have more of the
activator or stronger binding sites
you'll have stronger activation
repress repress and then and danced at
is a way to encapsulate all that and in
and read a sequence while encapsulating
those ideas and also provided as I say
null model because if you think that no
a core particular kind of cooperativity
matters or angela was talking about a
non-equilibrium actions matter you can
act compare it to see the well you know
in light of the data is that come out
and so I think it's a valuable null
model in that sense into this shape
matter this accessibility matter for for
for reading these sequences better and
also ensemble of models is a formalism
for what we know and do not know about
enhancer and towards systematic
experiment design I think it's valuable
as people are getting more and more
savvy about collecting high-resolution
data on individual enhancers in embryos
and other contexts like to thank all the
people who did the work Hasan is here
you can ask him questions during the
break fascinated deal probabilistic
landscape work branded the
regularization work pay tendered the
shape work and this was all started by
shin who was now an assistant professor
at uchicago and I cannot thank enough
star schwartzman for collaboration in
the funding agencies thank you very much
trying to follow your second partner on
this that's when you train your model on
one example essential
right and so you have known publishing
weight matrices for the factors that you
know from the previous knowledge that
play a role there yes and score get
scores with existing weight matrices and
you just learn essentially how important
is each side or each TF it's a TF
specific yes it's based on one example
one enhancer such a drastically
overfitting many many just right that's
right examples and the follow-up
experiment that's right there out which
ones are consistent that's right
right so we looked at the literature
there and one of the problems was that
we are not release sampling this so if
you I think if I understand your
question you know it's about adaptive
construction of the land of the of the
distribution via sampling right and
we're not will given these arbitrary
collection of points that are supposed
to be high in the landscape and they
came from some sampling followed by some
optimizations okay and now we don't have
any we can't do anything more we're
trying to just drape a landscape over
this so that's in that sense it's
different from the basin optimization
stuff Alex Oh Michael something mystical
literature is for next year okay sample
and try to estimate the other line
dances with a bunch of assumptions right
right right right now we have been
looking not not very deeply uh but we're
continuing to look at the literature
yeah